[Musique]
le festival 50 ans s'est terminée comme
il l'a débuté en musique
une troisième édition tournée vers le
4ème art le prix des cinémas a
récompensé à l'unanimité youssef le
gambré ce documentaire s'attache un
musicien et luthier youssef serra
locales comme on le voit dans le film il
habite trappe
c'est quelqu'un qui est sur
l'immigration qui sema avec une
française
donc on trouvait que son parcours était
vachement intéressant vachement positif
parce qu'en fait lui il veut y arriver
on a trouvé que c'était un comment
dirais-je à un beau film en fait sur le
sur le partage sur la tolérance voilà
c'est pour ça qu'on lui a décerné le
prix des cinémas de 50 ha je fais des
instruments je suis de la connaissance
avec les étrangers bah ça change
beaucoup pour moi
le prix tv 78 a été remis à une
réalisation suisse avec in his hand
caroline harnes et martina rider plonge
dans la tradition musicale des yéniches
un peuple semi-nomade le choix est
multiple il ya le thème qui était très
original et qui n'étaient pas connus de
nous avant de visionner le documentaire
il ya le lieu il ya la qualité des
images à la qualité du montage c'est
absolument évident il ya la découverte
même si on ne voit pas beaucoup mais
quand même d'un stéphane eicher qui dit
nous surprend même dans son langage
[Musique]
c'est ce qu'a déclaré le dos masculin le
prix troisième revient lui à anaïs
prosaïque réalisatrice des liens de
radigues l'écoutent virtuose